لاس فيجاس
هي عاصمة الترفيه في
العالم ،
لكن هذه الواحة الواقعة في صحراء نيفادا هي
أيضًا موطن لبعض أفضل
ملاعب الجولف
في العالم وبعض أفضل لاعبي العالم من
بينهم دانييل كانغ البالغة من العمر 28 عامًا والتي
ترقى إلى مستوى سمعتها
كواحدة  من أكثر اللاعبين الموهوبين في
الرياضة
دانيال ، مرحبًا بكم في لعبة الجولف الحية الآن
لجمهورنا الذين ربما
ليسوا على دراية بقصتك ، ربما يمكنك أن
تخبرنا قليلاً عن المكان
الذي أنت
منه وذكرياتك الأولى عن لعبة الجولف التي
ولدت فيها  لقد
نشأت وأنا في سان فرانسيسكو كاليفورنيا في قرية ويست ليك بكاليفورنيا
ودخل الجولف حياتي عندما كان عمري حوالي
12 أو 13 عامًا.
بدأ اللعب وكان جيدًا
حقًا بعد الخفافيش
وكل ما تحدث عنه
الجميع كان مدى روعته إلى أي مدى كان يضرب
الكرة وشعرت بالغيرة من الاهتمام ،
لقد تابعته أينما ذهب
على الرغم من  كونها متأخرة في اللعبة ،
لم يمض وقت طويل قبل أن ترى موهبة كانغ الطبيعية إلى
جانب علاقتها الوثيقة مع
شقيقها أليكس أنها مؤهلة لنا
المفتوحة في سن 14 عامًا فقط ، لم أكن أعرف
ما الذي كان مفتوحًا لنا.
قم بالتسجيل من أجلها ، لقد سجلني أخي
فيها
، وعندما فتحت لنا الباب ، كان الجميع
متحمسين للغاية
ولم أكن أعرف لماذا وقالوا إنه
كان تخصصًا وكان
ردي هو الاختصاصي لأنني كنت حقًا
في ذلك الوقت
في ممارسة فنون الدفاع عن النفس
ومشاهدة كأس العالم ، كنت من
محبي كرة القدم ومشجعي فنون الدفاع عن النفس أكثر
من
كرة القدم وكرة السلة والجولف
في عام 2010 ، فازت كانغ بأول
ألقابها لنا للهواة مع والدها
كانغ على الحقيبة وأعلنت  هي نفسها
كواحدة من أكثر الآفاق الموهوبة
في اللعبة وهي تتفوق على وجه مألوف في
جيسيكا كوردا
في المباراة النهائية للعب المباراة التي ربما
كانت واحدة من البطولات المفضلة
لدي طوال حياتي حتى يومنا هذا
لأن
والدي وأنا استمتعنا كثيرًا  لم يكن
ابو  كان الفوز كما لو كان
والدي يحاول فقط
إضفاء المرح والاستمتاع
بما يأتي مع التواجد في المنصب
سواء كان ذلك وقتًا أطول لمشاهدة التلفاز سواء كانت
أمي ستشاهدني على التلفزيون أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل ، لذا فأنت
تعرف الشيء التالي  ألعب ضد جيسيكا كوردا
في النهائيات
واعتقد الجميع أنها ستفوز مثلما
لم
يتحدث أحد على قناة الجولف عن
فوزي ولا أحد ،
أعني أنني لم أكن أحدًا ،
وأنا من أكثر الأشياء التي لا تنسى
بالنسبة لي هي  الحفرة الأخيرة
كان لدي أربعة تذييلات للفوز بالشيء بأكمله
، ونظرت إلى والدي ،
فقلت له ، هل يمكنني الحصول على تلفزيون
إذا صنعت هذا الوضع
واشترى لي ، قال نعم ، يمكنك
الحصول على تلفزيون في غرفتك  وقلت حسنًا ،
إنه يشبه فقط صنع الفطيرة ، يمكنك
الحصول على تلفزيون ، فقلت حسنًا ، لذا صنعته
واشترى لي تلفزيونًا
للتكيف مع اللعبة الاحترافية يستغرق
وقتًا ، وللأسف
بعد معركة مع السرطان
توفي والد دانييل في عام 2013
قبلها  تمكنت من تحقيق أول فوز
لها كمهنة
لقد مررت بالكثير
خلال السنوات الخمس الماضية ،
لقد
شعرت بأنني عمري 20 عامًا خلال
تلك السنوات الخمس
ولم يكن ذلك بسبب لعبة الجولف ولكنك
تعلم أنني تعرضت للكثير من
الخسائر وأنا  كنت أرغب في الفوز بشدة
لمدة عامين ، لم أكن أبدًا
يائسة في حياتي
أحاول الفوز وأموت وفشلت ، لم
أستطع الفوز بينما كان والدي لا يزال
موجودًا ولا أنظر إلى الوراء على أنه الأكبر  الفشل
، لم أستطع فعل ذلك
في عام 2017 ، انتهى أخيرًا البحث عن هذا الانتصار الأول بعيد المنال
في
كانغ للأزياء المذهلة حيث حصلت على لقبها الأول في lpga
وأول
تخصص لها حيث كانت تحمل وعاء طائر بعد
اقتراب شجاع في يوم 18
إلى  ختم بطولة PGA للسيدات في
تلال أوليمبيا
مع هذا الانتصار الأول بعيدًا عن الطريق الذي
شرعت فيه كانغ بسرعة في ترسيخ مكانتها
كواحدة من أفضل الفرق في العالم من خلال انتصارات lpga
في عام 2018
19 وانتصارات متتالية بعد
الإغلاق
في عام 2020 الآن كما ننظر  قبل ما تبقى
من هذا العام danielle th  هناك بعض
الأحداث الكبيرة في الأفق ،
فما هي أهدافك لعام 2021
أكثر من أي شيء أريد التنافس فيه
في الألعاب الأولمبية التي أعرفها مع الوباء
، ويخشى الجميع أنه سيتم
إلغاؤه ، لكن كان حلمي
أن أتنافس في الأولمبياد  منذ أن
كنت طفلاً وشاهدت الألعاب الأولمبية ، لقد
شاهدت كل دورة أولمبية
طوال حياتي والألعاب الأولمبية الشتوية الصيفية
لأتنافس فيها وألعب لعبة الجولف
الآن ، لم تكن الطريقة الأصلية التي أردت
التنافس فيها في  أولمبياد مع التايكوندو
ولكن
لمجرد التنافس فيها وإتاحة
الفرصة للفوز ،
أعد نفسي للحصول على فرصة هو هدفي الرئيسي
هذا العام